Good morning.
So we are here at the dairy.
We're giving a tour to a Brazilian group
that also has a dairy,
and they're selling into 80 milk which will be selling.
What are you doing?
You know, when we were in Brazil
is really when Dan and I both started
becoming more and more passionate about agriculture.
Because it wasn't a lot of,
um, like milk.
For instance,
when I'd go to the grocery store,
all they would have was, um,
shelf stable milk,
and it gave me a stomachache every time I drink it.
And so in Brazil, I,
who's always trying to find these little farms
which were prevalent,
are prevalent there.
There's still a lot of rural areas,
and so I was finding these little farms
to get raw milk from and fresh milk.
And so we started hanging out with these farmers
and people that were living off the land
or supporting their communities.
That's really when we fell in love with agriculture
and we were like, okay,
when we go back to the United States,
this is what we wanna do.
You know, we wanna,
um, get into farming,
Wanna support our family.
We don't just wanna do like
a hobby farm,
we want it to be like
our livelihood.
And so, um. Yeah,
that's really where it all blossomed
was when we were living in Brazil.
We were in San Paulo,
and, um. Yeah.
So it's so cool seeing this family here.
They've been Farming for a lot of years,
but now are marketing an a to a
to raw milk and fresh milk
to super mercados
at grocery stores
and also direct consumer.
So it's very, very cool.